and now here is a gentleman who is
positively one of the most charming
stars of today ladies and gentlemen
Richard Pryor
hi hi I liked the way you handled a
mother tongue well if there's anything I
like handling it's the old mother tongue
I thought I thought you were truly truly
magnificent in our opening number oh you
were nobody number yes I was the as a
tall blond guy in the middle Oh
it's a lovely suit yes is it expensive a
little bit yeah fireproof I don't
usually wear custom-made clothes but I
look to give customers start you know
well are you saying that you normally
buy things off the rack
no no just like the studio gives me the
clothes tomorrow like my last pictures I
looked at the budget I had two pair of
jeans and three t-shirts Lord million -
yeah it sounds about right
well carry on but don't rush awfully man
I want to tell you I know this is not
the right time but I won't say just how
much I love you how much I just you just
exude things that I would like to have
you're just great it's so funny and I'd
love to be just work with you one time
would be mean a lot to me yes I just I
just like the way you
hello the reason I'm here thank you my
friends
the reason I'm here tonight is because I
loved movies I can remember when I was a
kid back in Peoria Illinois I mean no
movie ever opened that I didn't sneak in
and see and I'd like to deliver my
inspirational message for the night is
to say that young people everywhere
never sneak into a movie walk up to the
box office and pay your ticket
especially if I have a piece of the
movie you can do anything you want to
with the popcorn I don't have any action
and now I'd like to bring out our next
two presenters who are coming here as
fast they move the cards
they're really from our RP because he's
from Superman and he's from Star Trek
Margot Kidder and William Shatner
before we begin Margo and George can you
click heartache thank you
Captain Kirk where'd you see it in outer
space yes a drive-in now to announce the
nominees for the best achievement in art
direction these artists are responsible
for creating the sets the design and the
overall look of a film the nominees are
any art direction by Dale Hennessy set
decoration by Marvin March Blade Runner
art direction by Lawrence G Paul and
David Schneider set decoration by winger
descent Gandhi art direction by Stuart
Craig and Bob Lang set decoration by
Michael circular La Traviata art
direction by Franco Zeffirelli set
decoration by Gianni Carranza wonderful
victor/victoria art direction by Roger
mosque Tim Hutchison and William Craig
Smith set direction by Harry Cortland
your turn Marva thank you your turn mark
the winners are Stuart Craig and Bob
Langer Gandhi and forceps
Stewart cray-pas black Michaels super
we share this with Norman Dorman Ren
Romney Erica our thanks to a brave team
and the bravest men of all Sir Richard
Attenborough thank you
the next stop on our studio tour will be
the camera department now I'll turn you
over to our guys now the young man who
is so funny a night shift Michael Keaton
and young lady can eat strawberries
better than anybody in the world we
stopped
this is terrific nice meeting you
because I we've never met before I know
I was looking for me behind the stage a
night
it's lovely meeting you I think we never
we had never you know I know I know we
never actually funny please tell me that
and I think fact I think was Albert
Einstein who said it's life kooky or
what
oh god I'm nervous enough okay we're
actually yet to compliment the
cinematographers that's right you guys
you know the you can take the finest
cast the best script and the most
sensitive director but unless you
somebody gets down and shoots that you
may as well be doing a radio show you
know movies can't exist without sound
but they can't exist without the image
right it's exactly console so we honor
the cinematography the soul of the
cinema which combines most both Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences the nominees
are ghosts volcano for dust boats
Allen da vo for ET the extra-terrestrial
Billy Williams and Ronny Taylor for
Gandhi and Nesta Al and rose for
Sophie's Choice
and on Reisman
and the winners are Billy Williamson
Ronnie side of abundance
I'm very happy to share this great honor
with my good friend Ronnie Taylor and to
also share it with our superb camera
crews grips and electrician's Indian and
British who working in harmony shot this
unique film and I especially sang my
wife Anne for her love and her support